straight ahead all lawn crying daily
the search is on for two toddlers
missing from their adopted parents home
in california a grandfather's sentence
his granddaughter dying after falling to
her death
from an open cruise ship window actors
team up to offer a big reward for
information
in the assault of a 91 year old man why
they say asian americans are being
targeted
a substitute teacher accused of lewd
acts in georgia don't know what
possessed her to think that was
normal or okay and the parents charged
an 11-year-old's death
one year after his body was found
stuffed in a storage bin
they faced multiple criminal charges
including child abuse poisoning and
torture
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
two little boys from california have
been missing now for well over a month
law and crimes angenette levy is here
with a plea from the boys adopted family
members
yeah brian no one has seen oren or orson
west since december 21st
and sadly police in california city
california
suspect foul play orrin west is only
four years old his younger brother orson
is three
the toddler's adoptive parents told
police in california city california
that they were in the backyard playing
and then vanished and might have walked
into the california desert
orrin and orson's extended family posted
a message over the weekend on mediums
saying they have been terrorized
they wrote for those who wish us harm we
will continue to pray that you pivot
your energy and make it all about the
search for oren and
orson the reward for the return of the
two boys has increased now to
and twenty thousand dollars i contacted
the california city police department
and i also tried to reach the adoptive
boys parents
neither of those attempts to reach the
people there were successful but we are
told
and have learned that the parents have
not been named suspects in the case
the fbi and the national center for
missing and exploited children
are both assisting with the case at this
time
brian thanks angenet joining us today is
retired assistant director of
counterintelligence for the fbi
frank figluzzi and terry austin frank
the reward for information as you heard
angenette say has risen to 120 000
authorities have received over 20 000
tips with no name suspects
what do you believe the next steps are
in finding those young children
yeah the fb the insertion of the fbi in
this case is critical because they bring
this national viewpoint to the case and
their database is filled with similar
crimes
and known suspects but the reward
thing is very interesting here because
rewards are not necessarily proven to
help solve the case but
rather they generate what we're doing
right now which is
more public discussion which is exactly
what's needed here
and the fbi knows how to ask the right
questions and these
so often the police come in and ask
neighbors when they do interviews
have you seen anything unusual did you
see anything unusual that day and the
reality that we know
is that actually it's not the unusual
it's the delivery man
the postal guy the construction guy that
you see
in the neighborhood every day and that
saw those kids
and saw an opportunity that's the focus
that needs to happen
who's been in that neighborhood
regularly and felt comfortable operating
there
now terry i i hate asking this question
i hope we find the children but it's
been
almost 50 days since the children went
missing and considering how young they
are
are you worried that we may not find
them alive
i am worried brian i mean they were only
three and four years old and of course
if they wandered out into the desert
area
they would not be able to survive even
adults would not be able to survive
but it seems as though the police chief
thinks that
there's something that went awry that
they're not roaming around somewhere
that someone took them from the yard or
from the house
so i'm hoping if that's the case that
they are still safe and sound
maybe with a relative and soon we will
find out exactly what happened to these
two little boys
i join you in those hopes terry for sure
and jeanette the police were back at the
parents house
recently what exactly happened yeah
there have been several searches for the
children they've actually
searched some areas in the ground to see
if there had been any
movement in the ground some disturbances
where children may have been buried or
anything else
some published reports suggest that
animal remains were found but
nothing indicating that the children had
been buried there they even went and
searched a house in bakersfield
where the adoptive father used to live
because the family had just in september
of last year moved to california city
california they did not find
anything to indicate that the children
had been buried on that property either
thanks for the update everyone a judge
in puerto rico has sentenced a
grandfather for the heartbreaking death
of a little girl
terry austin has the latest brian
salvatore nello was sentenced to three
years probation
as part of his deal to plead guilty to
negligent homicide
prosecutors say anello dropped his 18
month old granddaughter
from an open cruise ship window docked
in puerto rico
chloe wiegand died from the 150-foot
fall the judge agreed anello can serve
probation in his home state of indiana
according to testimony from the family
anello helped
raise the girl he claims he held her up
to the window
thinking the glass would hold her the
window was in fact
open the fact that the grandfather pled
guilty in the criminal case
mean that royal caribbean is off the
hook in any way in the civil case
absolutely not brian in fact the civil
case is still proceeding and
there's a good claim against the cruise
line because
there are laws that state the cruz has
to make sure
that their passengers are safe so that
includes window guards etc
and even though the father or the
grandfather
pled guilty he really said and the
family says
that this was an accident so in fact you
could have
both the criminal case proceeding and
the wrongful death action proceeding at
the exact same time one has nothing to
do with the
other yeah so maybe he's pleading guilty
because again don't want to bring the
family through a trial
you take the probation you're admitting
guilt but that doesn't leave royal
caribbean off the hook
maybe something more will develop in the
civil case thank you terry
still ahead on law and crime daily the
reward and arrest of a suspect accused
of violently shoving a 91 year old man
to the ground
but first the viral video of a man
accused of streaking at the super bowl
who he is and the charges he's facing
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
a five-year-old girl remains in critical
condition after a multi-vehicle crash
involving the kansas city chiefs
assistant coach
police in kansas city say brit reed
struck two trucks pulled over on the
side of a highway
near the team stadium last thursday
according to a search warrant reed
admitted to having two to three drinks
and taking adderall before getting
behind the wheel
a four and five-year-old child were
taken to the hospital with five-year-old
ariel sustaining life-threatening
injuries
reid's father and head coach of the
chiefs andy reid told reporters after
the game that his heart bleeds for
everybody involved in the crash
brit reed did not travel with the team
to florida for the super bowl
and a florida man is facing a
misdemeanor charge after running onto
the field at the super bowl game
sunday night yuri andrade is accused of
streaking wearing a pink leotard
as he tried to spin his way away from
security the sheriff's office posted
video of the incident on facebook
saying that it was the best tackle of
the night andrade was released from jail
on a 500 bail
actors daniel day kim and daniel wu are
offering a 25 000
reward for information that helped find
the suspect behind the attack of a 91
year old man
surveillance video shows the man walking
down a street in a chinatown district of
oakland california
the suspect is seen coming from behind
and shoving the man to the ground
oakland police say the same suspect also
attacked a 60 year old man
and 55 year old woman the same day the
actors posted on social media
that they're teaming up to raise
awareness about crimes against asian
americans
former homicide prosecutor bernardo
villalona says proving hate crime
charges
could be difficult for investigators
these are the cases that makes you want
to be a prosecutor
to prosecute someone who can be so cold
and callous to prey upon the elderly
and push a 91 year old man down to the
ground
and continue walking that man unprovoked
not doing anything to you and you just
throw that person
down to the ground come on unacceptable
unacceptable unfortunately
trying a hate crime case you're going to
have to prove that the reason
that the man pushed a 91 year old man
down
was because of his race his origin so
it's going to be difficult in that
regard
but just for the assault itself this is
uncalled for
it appears their efforts have worked the
district attorney's office says they've
now charged a suspect in the attack
i now have announcing that we have filed
committing a crime against an elderly
person
back to break down the apparent
targeting of those in the asian-american
community
is frank faguzzi and terry austin frank
it appears the authorities have
identified a suspect who is already in
jail for elder abuse
that charge plus the three victims could
the targets also be
of the elderly yeah so the track record
here is very helpful but i can tell you
that
fbi profilers would offer a tremendous
amount here here's why
they would pour over this suspect's life
was he
fired by someone with a certain
ethnicity or does he have
some hatred toward elders that it's
reflected in other aspects of his life
maybe his social media maybe his
computer hard drive but the fact that
he's already been on the radar
for elder abuse tells us that's likely a
motivator
but profilers would dig into his psyche
and try to figure out what that
motivation is because it will help them
decide on charges in terms of
prosecution
yeah i can help for deciding on charges
and also for a conviction if they can
get that information in front of a jury
now terry serial racist elder abuser or
something else what do you think
it could be a combination of both and
the good thing is that under the
california penal code
you can be charged with a hate crime
obviously
if it is as far as race is concerned but
also as far as
age is concerned i mean you just have to
show that you're singling out people
because of those characteristics
and the offense can really be just for
the hate crime or it can be
an aggravating factor or it can be um
you know enhancement
under this section so hopefully they
will be able to determine like frank
said the intent
and then after that they will be able to
put the hate crime on top of that so the
penalties will be greater
yeah like frank said it's going to take
a little bit of digging maybe into that
person's background social media things
of that nature
and maybe also their mental health to
see where that may lead
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily a georgia substitute teacher
accused of lewd acts in the classroom
plus the brothers of a victim goes after
her murder
in court the video the court hearing and
the sentence still ahead
an ohio man was sentenced to life in
prison for killing his pregnant wife
long crime founder and host of the a e
series court camp
tells us the hearing didn't exactly go
as planned
we take you inside the muskogee county
courthouse for the sentencing
of zidarius platt platz on trial for the
murder of his pregnant wife
jelani platt he faces multiple charges
including
aggravated assault a weapons charge and
feticide
the destruction of a fetus according to
investigators
platt choked jelani then shot her in the
head
here's platt on day one of what is sure
to be an emotionally charged trial
seated off camera just a few feet from
platte is gerald carter
brother of the slain victim
officers restrained the devastated
carter who continues to scream in anger
and frustration
he cries helplessly removed from the
court
[Music]
court officers hold carter down but he
refuses to let up
and things could get worse as one of
them has a
taser pressed against carter's back
[Music]
eventually the officer puts the taser
back in the holster
and tries his best to calm carter down
[Music]
throughout this struggle heartbroken
family members look on
though things begin to settle minutes
after the initial incident
carter's anguish can still be seen and
heard
by everyone in the courtroom
before the trial reconvenes judge bobby
peters
bans carter from returning to the
courtroom but doesn't pursue any charges
the outburst has no effect on the
prosecution's case
as the defendant is convicted on all
accounts
platt sentenced to two consecutive life
sentences plus five years for the
weapons charge
to be served in duly state prison in
georgia
when we come back police announced
charges for the death of an 11-year-old
boy found stuffed in a storage bin
why the boy's father and stepmother are
now in jail next
[Music]
a substitute teacher in georgia is
behind bars accused of lewd acts
in the classroom where children could
see
angenette levy is here with more on the
disturbing allegations
yeah brian amelia wrestler was a
substitute teacher in carroll county
georgia she's facing 19 counts of
molestation
involving second graders that she was
teaching now it's important to point out
that in georgia molestation does not
have to
include actual physical touching
and the sheriff's office there says
wrestler masturbated in the classroom
and a video of that act
actually ended up on social media that's
how the investigation
started from what we understand
she videoed it herself um
and then disseminated it um we're not
sure if she
that's still part of the investigation
if she sent it to someone directly and
then they posted it up to social media
or if she did it herself obviously
children have to be interviewed
differently than adults so we will have
to do forensic interviews on those
children
to see what if anything they saw you
know it could be that some saw it and
some didn't
so we're we're still trying to navigate
through that right now
he is actually the spokesperson for
carroll county georgia she says that
when deputies first approached amelia
wrestler she was actually taken aback
then they showed her the video and she
asked for an attorney so they never got
the chance to really speak with her
about that video and the allegations
when wrestler appeared in court
a judge denied bail for her brian we'll
send it back to you
what a strange case thanks anjanet a
father and stepmother are facing
multiple criminal charges nearly a year
after police found an 11 year old boy
dead in a storage bin placerville police
announced the arrest of jordan and
lindsey piper
police say roman lopez was found during
a search of the couple's home
on january 11 2020. lopez was living
there with his biological father
stepmother and seven other children
police wouldn't say
why they're bringing the charges now but
say they believe roman was abused
poisoned and tortured
back for legal analysis are frank
fagluzzi and terry austin
frank authorities say this was no simple
case considering
how much the defendants moved and the
forensics but what do the charges of
abuse and the facts that
so many of the children who were in that
home were put into protective services
so this would be a complicated case even
without
physical relocations of the suspects and
and even without all the other children
that have been in their care
but now it's complicated by those
factors because
each of those children will need to be
particularly
skillfully interviewed as to any abuses
they either
witnessed or experienced themselves and
the other factor here is the moves the
physical relocations
might even be a clue that they kept
moving to
avoid witnesses or move into other
jurisdictions etc to evade
detection and then lastly i'm fascinated
by the fact that two people
are engaged or knowledgeable of this
because it's
very rare thankfully that two together
would have
knowledge and permit this to happen it's
not uncommon it's not something that's
never happened
but it's still still considered rare so
they may eventually testify against each
other we'll have to wait and see
but there's more charges something tells
me there's more charges on the way for
these two
now frank i kind of want to piggyback
off that last thought that there's more
charges
could this whole evasion idea or the or
because you know how sometimes they say
it's not the crime but it's the cover-up
do you think that that evasion and that
so-called cover-up could lead to
additional charges as well
well there's a couple of ways this could
go additional charges could come in the
form of additional victims and i think
that's where this may be headed but also
we could see one
one of them charged with accessory after
the fact
or harboring because they may have had
guilty knowledge but done nothing
about it don't be surprised if you see
that charge coming
i can see that happening and thanks for
the update on that as well with
additional charges coming up
terry frank kind of touched on it but i
want you to kind of dive in a little bit
deeper
the father is accused of failing to
provide water and the mother
for poisoning roman the young child do
you see these defendants as frank
alluded to
us either pointing the finger at each
other or maybe sticking together
throughout the whole case
you know i think this might be one of
those cases where we see
the parents pointing the finger at each
other it's a very
tragic case obviously i mean there were
seven children in their custody so you
do have to think
what is going on in that household with
these other children
and to say that the father is failing to
provide food and water
i could very easily see jordan piper
saying
look that wasn't my responsibility that
was my wife's responsibility
she should have been doing that so you
can't charge me with that and look i'm
going to point the finger at her
she should have been making sure they
got nourishment the other issue is the
fact that lindsay piper
she's accused of poisoning this 11 year
old boy
so that's a very aggressive charge
that's basically saying
she went out of her way to kill him so i
definitely think we
might see some going against each other
here
and particularly i think if the
authorities
want to get someone to turn on the other
they might go to the father
and have him turn against the mother
yeah i could definitely see that playing
out
and we've of course seen that sometimes
where two parents are accused of a crime
and the father takes this kind of
antiquated um idea of well providing
food or clothing isn't my job it's the
mother's job
it's gonna be interesting to see how
that plays out of course i think both
parents are
responsible for that of course uh frank
thank you for joining us terry
thank you as well and thank you for
joining us here along crime daily we'll
see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you